greetings from podcast ville tonight's
Church of what's happening now is
brought to you by out it
listen if you're looking for supplements
on it is the way to go from shrimp
export to alpha brain listen you can't
[ __ ] lose you understand me now they
got the kettlebells they got the way to
vest I can't help you with that as far
as supplements
I'll get your 10% off go to Hahnenkamm
right now and press in church bad you
get 10% off your first order delivered
to your [ __ ] door like a savage
number 2 are you lonely
no talk to me you know I'm your uncle
Joey are you lonely
are you second time have you tried
online dating chances are you're running
too lazy text messages dead-end
conversations random matches that don't
turn into dates you hooked up with them
they tell you they were which in their
previous life is something but have you
seen the success stories from eHarmony
real people finding real matches with
the Harmony understand me
this is what I'm gonna do start your
journey to love to a satisfying
meaningful relationship it can be fun to
play around without online dating apps
but when you're ready to seriously fall
in love with somebody I mean you know
they come over you rub each other's toes
that type of stuff there's only one app
that's built to bring your real love and
that's he harmony come see how a harmony
can change your life go to Hima eat
harmony calm right now and get started
there's no reason to be sitting in
Donuts with a cat at the coat Church at
checkout all right Lee kick this
[ __ ] meal
what's happening you bad [ __ ]
no Joey here or be Marcus in the
[ __ ] house what's up my man I
can't call it man the flying Jews here
looking [ __ ] dapper number one if he
came to the comedy store last night to
support whatever man
thank you I owe you my [ __ ] life
whether we get on that we got the
opportunity to showcase that's all that
matters and I was prepared
you can't take [ __ ] like that on the
chin or if not though eat you alive I
know this now at 55 it's a tough pill to
swallow when you're 35 but I'm telling
you sometimes I know it's better than a
yes so whatever happens I did
my job I worked hard I worked out I
brought it and now it's up to Netflix to
make the decision whatever way I'm not a
slow loser
I'll figure out a [ __ ] special even
if I do it my man Joe Rogan let's say
that's the key to life that is
absolutely the key to life man it's
responsible for the process just
responsible for [ __ ] sending it I
just want you to be prepared like that
if I don't it's the most important I
didn't know at 25 and 27 and 28 and 32
preparation is the key if you're
prepared you going to battle you know
every time you go on stage any time you
play tennis any time in your head it has
to be a battle so when you go into
battle as long as you're prepared and
you know in your heart that you prepared
I mean Monday night I went to a final
open mic the fourth wall there's no ego
here involved this is about being the
best that you could be you know when I
first moved here didn't like me they
just people didn't like me it's the way
it was so my goal wasn't to become a
producer or director or a [ __ ]
magician comic my goal is to become the
funniest person I could become because
they can't take that from you yep you
know my mother used to always say don't
care if you're a janitor as long as
you're the best janitor on the floor you
know I'm trying to be the best janitor
they can't take that away from me that
takes the pressure off when all you when
you put in all the work and all you're
responsible for is just showing up and
doing your best and then let it be man
you know like don't judge yourself based
on the outcome just know that you gave
it and that's it that's it I never used
to do that I would go to those showcases
never prepare six minutes I never forget
Joe when he was really hot some fear
factor they gave him a slot on Friday
nights
they gave him there was a show on NBC
called Friday's it was on after the news
after it was like the original what's
the kid man it's big he has the later
show on NBC and they came a-courtin he
was kind of like James Corden even
there's one even after Jim Cole uh that
guy Joe Martin Taylor yeah car it was
Joe hosted that Friday and it was gonna
be Joe's comedy buddies to do it and
I'll never forget that
Sussman and the guy from NBC were there
and it was like stealing it was my job
to lose it all I lost it and in that day
Joe was
[ __ ] best why he wasn't there hmm but
he said you we went against what you did
you went up then played dice instead of
[ __ ] doing you know I can't give you
an inch I was really upset because she
really wanted me to get this yeah he
loves you but I didn't prepare you know
and and those little lessons that you
learned like you never take even the
six-minute showcase for granted now like
I never when I go to the fourth wall
even it's a bunch of open-mike young
kids with the same dream I had I go to
the destroy that [ __ ] place you know
whatever I got because now you learn you
know that's how you get ready for
whatever the [ __ ] band and you have
to learn that way you know like you have
to [ __ ] it up a few times like whatever
you did wrong know that you needed to do
that wrong in order to get better the
next time you know like you had to [ __ ]
that one up so that you could be as
great as you are now like it's all part
of the process it's so funny like I knew
that I had to do a set before the Comedy
Store last night and I went to the
Improv and just ate a bag of dicks
because I [ __ ] knew I was only need a
bag of dicks I just knew it I knew that
if I went in there loose I'm the type of
guy would never be a good UFC fighter
because you knocked me out in the first
round it's over I'm just getting started
yes would you knock me out once I smell
the smelling salt what happened he
knocked out ways like give me five
minutes give me one more shot at this
and now you have I'm one of those guys I
got a second wind I'm sailing yeah I'd
be all-in 11 but I'd [ __ ] I'd be eight
nine eight zero in the locker room
against me I have to it like I'd [ __ ]
them up and I get to spend here
something like that you know like a
knock him out with a karate kick I
understand that when I used to play
basketball I would be for the big games
I'd be so nervous that I'd intentionally
make like hard contact with someone on a
screen or something on deep and
sometimes get a foul called because I
just needed to feel something hard like
go straight as hard as I could to the
hole and to feel that contact and then
like feel something and then I could
loosen up like I had to get hit or hit
somebody and I was like alright now
we're putting out we'll play and then
you have to play fall damage yeah
exactly something like that where'd you
get a basketball scholarship should I
forget I didn't get a scholarship but I
went to University of Richmond and I was
I had some you know state honors for for
high school basketball player with a
nationally ranked team you know I could
play but I knew that I wasn't going to
the NBA no I just played with no I
played with the team for a bit but um
never made before
see that's what gave me the blueprint
for calmly was basketball like I loved
basketball I was a kid but I was [ __ ]
horrible and the year I made the team we
went oh and nine they even make me feel
worse and that summer I swore that was
never gonna happen again that was not
gonna happen he's great and I went to
like [ __ ] I went to sacred you know
uh Bob Hurley's camp from Saint
Anthony's I went to there in the eighth
grade and I actually got picked to go to
five star basketball camp yeah I mean I
remember that was wine wine stain so I
was pretty good my [ __ ] it's not
Weinstein it's a different he just died
Finkelstein he was like the Jewish guy
that you called whenever you needed a
college basketball player he picked you
in those days so he ran a camp in the
summer is called five-star basketball
camp which like what the summer I was
there Dominique Wilkins was a counselor
like you didn't know but you knew they
were in college like my particular
counselor in my room was Kenny Dennard
Kenny they're not actually started on
that [ __ ] Duke team it was I was in
the eighth grade I still remember one
outstanding thing about Kenny Dennard
that it was hot as [ __ ] it was
Pittsburgh it's hot it's humid June and
he would always have a hooded sweatshirt
and one day I go why do you [ __ ] wear
this sweatshirt he turned around and
bent over and then his help in his hood
he had a baby skunk you're [ __ ] [ __ ]
no that's the first time I ever and I he
let me pet it and then he brought it in
the room and I let me let that song by
Rick James was the hottest song like
like I when I came from Cuba my when I
came from Cuba I don't think white kids
understood me so my only friends were
black and my best best friend friend the
world was black last week somebody and I
New York a black guy came up to me shook
my hand hold me down he goes with these
white [ __ ] don't know is you're
just an old-school [ __ ] and he walked
away I know what the [ __ ] that guy to
say to me I went back to the hotel he
was right because that was my first
exposure like I learned from these
brothers and then but then I lost
contact brothers and I start playing
basketball again and that was the summer
that Rick James came out with his first
[ __ ] hit and it was called you and I
and you know you have like rest periods
where you you woke up at 7:00 you didn't
eat breakfast and you did sprints and
drill suicides their suicides know they
have a specific no I was donating the
football camp that had suicides and then
you went to breakfast and then you broke
down the move of the day remand and then
you have to know you just play ball is
she like that but whenever that song by
Rick James went on black people lost it
and they were playing black music on the
radio
yeah it's called you and I have you have
you ever heard you and I have heard it
but yeah it like the beginning of my
black people can be garden each other
like that summer was like Dominique
Wilkins it was all it's all so when you
have those those songs that go with your
Bob with your boy when it came out to
time for some action by red man every
time I still hear that song I get hype I
get butterflies I'm like oh let's go
let's go
time for some back time time for some
time for some action I love war and I
would try and dunk but I couldn't dunk
enough and if I actually did that
because I was always right on the cusp
because I couldn't really palm the ball
that well if I did junk I for sure
air-balled my first shot cuz I was so
fired up but I dunked in warmups
I had kicks yeah I got a kick so I could
grab the rim mm-hmm downtown left Bergen
like I missed a dunk one time I got
really light like 168 and I could get up
there yeah when I went to Sacred Heart
Oh whatever st. Anthony's basketball
camp which was called superstar
basketball camp
I went outstanding rebounder that week
so that's why he was recruiting me there
trying to go to st. Anthony's you
recruiting me a kid why he'll Donnell
and chuckling Green who shut up am I
Nyak he's to coach a Ramapo Division
three they just went to the Final Four
in Division three he stuck with it he's
a [ __ ] coach I got a couple buddies
one guy Greg her and the coaches I went
to five-star with him we won't have a
bus together he was from Saint Peter's
Prep but I used the blueprint from my
basketball days for Connolly which was
you know you play every day like yeah
you just play all day that I would get
up and shoot 300 shots like Jerry West
first I would find like somewhere then
nobody would go I wouldn't leave I
wouldn't put down a basketball until I
made three three-pointers in a row and
that was my rule from when I was like 11
years old to when I was 18 years old
like if I touched it I had to make three
in a row see when I was growing up those
little people sometimes then sometimes I
would take me three for three minutes
you know I just knock them out sometimes
if I was off I'd be out there 15 minutes
20 minutes frustrated [ __ ] hit to miss
the third dammit I just want to go but I
had that ritual and it you know I ended
up being one of the best three-point
shooters in Texas from that same ritual
so anything you take deep you like you
learn those lessons it doesn't matter
what it is with this basketball or
ping-pong or violin or whatever take it
deep don't just dabble take something
deep if your fear of dad and you have
kids or mom have you kids take anything
deep because the lessons come when you
really push to that you know upper limit
of what's pasta it's crazy I went deep
with basketball and I have a taste of my
freshman year like it was a no-brainer
if he looked at all eight schools I was
going to be one of the starting forwards
on the freshman there's a no-brainer
Saint Anthony's one of me I would have a
start in life American talk this guy
just didn't like me coming here and I
was 13 and it was the hardest [ __ ]
lesson that I ever had like when you're
touted to do that and you know what he
had his reasons I was an offensive
machine and I could rebound but my
defense was a little weird because I was
always going for the steal mmm I knew
how to hold your shirt I knew how to
hold your shorts
myah the seventh grade teacher was he
still in the Hall of Fame for
free-throws in college John Burroughs
still made
if you ever play ball with him he was
very handy with you
he was like Earl Monroe Walt Frazier you
know if you watch them to play they're
gonna take that ball and you didn't
dribble around because they knew how to
flip you it would sit and one that a lot
of people could do that Paul Westphal
and Don busi had that combination where
as guards they know how to turn you and
take the ball from the wall Frazier
would pick your [ __ ] pocket and
there's pictures you can still find
pictures of Walt Frazier picking your
pocket and Earl Monroe holding your
t-shirts like this but you wouldn't grab
them like this you put a finger in it
put hold down I mean so you could move
they lock you down you know I was I was
taught to do a screen like this cover
your balls yeah cover your chest and
[ __ ] take him out yeah that's how I
was taught in North Bergen to do a
screen to great Julius Erving the great
Julius Erving taught me a move the great
Julius Erving was basically a cheetah
and I'll tell him this to his face I
love him he's my idol hi he's my idol
but Julius Erving had a move that he
cheated and the NBA let him get away
with if you watch him he used to hook
you mmm Julius Erving well he got the
ball he get the dribble and he would
hook your waist that's his illegal [ __ ]
watch will Shepherd that human a guy
named Lloyd free not worry there was a
plan for the Philadelphia 76ers that was
the best sixth man in the league when
Julius Erving first the one the ABA
defunct Julius Erving with the
Philadelphia had a strong team him
George McGinnis Colby but dad's bra Kobe
Bryant's dad
they had a white guard named Doug
Collins who was sensational he was
defending the house yeah and the point
guard was Henry Bibby see if you can
find that why was it that Tito said if
you ain't cheating you ain't trying
waitron see if you can find the video
lottery I read an interesting article
about him about - we sit on Twitter
somebody found an article a newspaper
how many points would he really have
school
if there was a three-point there was a
three-point line yeah he did his head
got big at the end and he changed his
name to world be free
his name was Lloyd free seems you could
find Lloyd free highlights this guy bro
when I watched him play I would lose my
[ __ ] mind
because there was two players in the
league that had this gift at the time it
was Lloyd free and a little guy in
Seattle named downtown Freddie brown all
right so basically yeah guy had put the
first one first look he had 35 points
against the Celtics world be free well
see if they show his highlights his
shooting highlights this guy was a
[ __ ] machine the six is four years
had machines that had that other [ __ ]
lunatic off so let's see if damn this is
it
look at this [ __ ] sandwich and he had
beautiful form yeah I mean I very high
yeah
everything he did was high but then that
showed he was [ __ ] 40-foot boy this
is his [ __ ]
yeah yeah that boy came watch him watch
him to say he could pop he was popping
on [ __ ] that was mob whatever
from them looking a little bad yeah oh
[ __ ] when he was a sixer against the
Lakers another killer from Manila look
look at there you go
[ __ ] the ceedric this is Julian look
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] that's awesome I
told you you watch now you still follow
cuz this will never happen again
I don't know man the Warriors Cavs is
closest I love the Warriors but I can't
I'm not sure about you looking really Oh
nothing but river ball Jesus Christ
on to people look at my he just walked
back like when and then but then he was
the best six man in the league he was
like gonna had Steve mix at the time
Jesus Christ
he was the best six mentally movers
Smith came in whenever you were down
Tanana and he go back when you up six
that's what his gift look at Julia's
behind them trailing oh [ __ ] he was only
a single one Doug yeah smooth that's my
move I like that much butter but there
was a dude that play for Seattle see a
SuperSonics when I was a kid his name
was Shawn Kemp no before Shawn Kemp it
was downtown Freddy Brown and his
brother they called Hibbert he was they
were both from Brooklyn or something and
his brother they called him the wizard
he was God he played somewhere else
but Freddy Brown I don't know if he had
like an alcohol problem he'd be sitting
on the bench like you just called him in
when you needed 20 points right like he
would he was a chubby guy yeah don't
like me like six foot one and [ __ ] I
he'd be sent at the end of the bench
with a brown bag [ __ ] and there we go
you know I go ahead Freddy and he were
like but he tell the coast coach I am
playing no Devers
you could see the footage even flailing
when they put him in he'd always whisper
something to the coach coach what we
need eight points watch my [ __ ]
he just got them hot forties on your ass
Bam Bam Bam bring you back and then call
it timeout coach cocktail and they will
put it back at the end up back in the
day watching people smoke cigars in the
vents that old Celtics coach I mean it's
just different eras of a boring writing
that when people allowed to smoke yeah
line up that victory cigar on the bench
inside smoking a cigar while your team's
up like five used to smoke it when the
game was still within reach just to
intimidate them this would be like this
[ __ ] games in the bag I'm like my
cigar [ __ ] it's over it's [ __ ]
over crazy man
how's the audit world treat you it's so
good it's so go we get movin always man
and I get to meet so many cool
[ __ ] like they come through and
you get to tap into their head see what
makes them great you know like this
offseason retraining with Jake Arrieta
who's across from Lance Armstrong who's
across from Earl Thomas and it's just
like damn these are like legends and you
get to hang with them and learn from
them and and see what they're up to
how to Academy with open floor it's been
open like almost five years
it's open to anybody yeah we have like
500 regular members and then all the
athletes and pros that come through and
they have everything there Jiu Jitsu I
know the guys well bring Muay Thai yeah
bamboo tie jujitsu yep yeah I've got the
whole thing it's a full you know it's
like a full epicentre of all things
human optimization is [ __ ] right it's
paradise for me you know I built like
the playground that I would dream about
when I was a kid where I could go do
Muay Thai and Jiu Jitsu and lift weights
and trained kettlebells and hit a sauna
hit a cryo and it's like and have a
great cafe making me keto shakes and
it's in my office that's where I spend
10 hours a day I'm spending 10 hours a
day in paradise who's the guy I see on
Instagram who works there who's like
doing Turkish get ups with I think we're
humans yeah it's crazy
my most vulgar shout out to a primal
swell dude he's a [ __ ] savage he does
what he can take a girl whole from lying
down they'll be curled up in a circle
and he'll be holding them up in the air
straight arm and then he'll go from a
girl girl 120 530 pounds a sexual
harasser and then he'll go from from his
back to a standing position holding her
up in the air and then back down again
Meryl look-alike night like he's not
that buff
I don't know about that yours a lot
bigger than that but you know he's just
trained consistently every single day
putting in the work it's you know I used
to know when he was young we would spar
in my old garage with Roger Huerta and
we'd go out and he was 17 and he was
just a kid and he's just watched him
take like what you said take something
so seriously just do it every single day
until he got better and [ __ ] better
and [ __ ] better and now he's killing
it man he's like one of our like local
homegrown superstars it's beautiful to
watch that it's beautiful to watch
somebody like just take something that
they and just
take it to the end take it all the way
to the end and now he's doing Turkish
get-ups with [ __ ] human human yeah
you know how Berto really inspired me to
use the club bells that's why I got the
club bells mm I really like him what I
can't believe I only do like 5 or 6
exercise yeah and I do my mix them up
I'm like a circuit training ring if I
can't make a jiu-jitsu or Muay Thai I
got a bag back then I got the different
size bats and I gotta mix it up a little
kettlebell workout I just do like 30
seconds on each you know but when I
first went to our Burgos I couldn't get
up on my wrist from hitting the bag all
those years would not rap song like in
fun gorilla my wrist got [ __ ] up over
the years brick mason like when I would
pick up the bricks I could feel my wrath
and he introduced me to club you know
the club bowels I'm not no gazania
whatever you lean either his buddy is
really big into it and then I talk about
my shoulders the problems I have my
shoulder took I can't believe what I do
at the club bowels now compared when I
first started the club bells I can
barely do five pounds yep and I just
work really helped open up the joints
you know we heal through movement that's
what people think like oh I'm hurt you
know a lot of times the movement is
actually what's gonna tell the body how
to heal to open things up to get the
muscle systems working to get the joints
fluid like movement is is healing it's
crazy how over the years people have
been you know workouts have changed we
we have evolved so much you know when I
was a kid and I want to workout I've
bought muscle and fitness and Joe Weider
was everything yeah and the Barbarian
brothers waiting 36 eggs a day and and I
it's all about size then this is all
about size then it was I would stress
430 grams of protein per meal or five
meals a day I was making these shakes at
night you know milk ice cream
wheat germ great to be the man you gotta
out yet the man in those days there was
just no flavor prey was egg milk protein
that's it there was no chocolate there
was no vanilla it was egg and milk
you know yeah it was five set to six per
body part nobody ever talked five sets
for six that sounds like cardio Joey you
want five sets of three no I said to sit
behind the backs of 180 you know there
was no Kurt there was we had no
dumbbells everything was straight bell
workouts you know which makes you a
[ __ ] gorilla my friend built a lap
machine but before that it was all bent
over rows [ __ ] with 180 you know fives
and that was it and that was it then
later on we incorporated one-arm [ __ ]
poles but that was it
you know and your goal was to eat
coolant that's all we ate total were
[ __ ] soreness tuna no no chicken
breast no chicken breast wasn't even my
popular that it was [ __ ] pulled out
of a can [ __ ] no mayo eat the [ __ ]
Tony shut your [ __ ] mouth and then
when I got locked up I got into it and
when you get locked up when you see
those guys jump it's because you eat
sardines in prison like [ __ ] you
know those are good for you I ate
[ __ ] so many sardines when I'm left
prison I was in tip-top shape I can
[ __ ] [ __ ] up I was about 195
prison diet the prison died you have to
run and you have to lift yeah he's so
bored you will live six days a week
there's no recuperation recuperate go to
prison
see if there's big corporation that's
all [ __ ] well yet they do put bad
[ __ ] we're gonna every day
yeah there's no recalling it the muscles
need joints and love what protein does
the other blender in jail has no blender
in jail those [ __ ] joking up
the yolk dudes that you see they figure
out old school ways mm-hmm how'd it get
[ __ ] yo yeah when I was in jail I was
a kitchen I was in charge of the kitchen
supplies so the stock was off the
premises disconnected from the jail so I
know a couple brothers in there they've
been doing steroids they were doing D
ball winstram I had a bar and they would
give why he gonna do steroids if you
can't get [ __ ] I don't get it because
they want to just be yoked in presence
so you don't become a [ __ ] that's why
these guys these guys got it
present looking like me and left you
know that was what they do that I was
imprisoned they went in there like I
said to you there was no internet you
whatever Joe Weider told you you did and
then you know there was some plots and
Mike münster and those type of
bodybuilders and every month they would
give you their workouts
I remember reading Arnold's encyclopedia
bodybuilding yes going through it
looking going to the intermediate sets
and doing all the intermediate said yeah
there's lots yeah
bench mix for five sets of pull-ups and
yeah I remember that was that super sets
every so straight ball curl with
alternating exhausting alternating curls
and then Diamond push-ups
oh really get your arms going I mean
that's and now you have this complete
different world you have this world of
MMA that's opened up you know like I
said T I'm gonna meet Sergio Oliva and
ask him how he got big and he told me in
Spanish would be think on calling it
that means take like a [ __ ]
people that's how you got this big he's
like we think on calling it
wait day up Rowley Frijole white beans
and rice in a steak three times a day
your muscles will get even look weight
nutrition has gone over the years
everything is leveled up you know it's
the combination of the practice society
because it's had to because the
competition is so [ __ ] savage now you
know you watch some of these top
athletes and what they do it's so
precise
you know everything they're training the
muscle systems that they're activating
the recovery protocols the supplements
they're dialing in you know we just
partner with one of the top sports
nutrition companies in the world is
coming to called exos and they send like
a third of the people who go to the NFL
Combine go through them their training
most of the top athletes in the world
and everything is just measured out they
get their own custom shakes their own
supplement protocol we're providing the
supplements now and and every workout is
dialed in every workout has metrics they
have 3d scanning z' to check your
movement patterns i mean it's it gets
really really tight at the top and then
there's also the other side which is
just going back to the super basic so
you get the really high tech and then
you go way back to the basics I mean
kettlebells those came those are
measurements of dry goods in Russia and
the strong men in Russia were like
having contests pissing contest figuring
out who could lift the heaviest ones and
that's how kettlebells develop the
club's comeback from ancient Persia the
steel maces come back from ancient
Persia the pail juanny wrestlers the
warrior elite training with ghada's and
and practicing the swings that would
knock somebody's head off in battle you
know these old practices are now mixing
with the new science and the crop of
athletes that are coming off a [ __ ]
phenomenal ok what do you guys think
speaking of that like what do you think
when you look at these current NBA
players even if you don't know who they
are when you just look at their bodies
and like what they're able to do and
they can play with her close to 40 now
and it's a different way it's when I was
growing up your palm was dirty too
you know a guy like Dave Winfield 36
they didn't really have they didn't know
how to really handle athletes after 36
and I used baseball as a as an adage
let's just use baseball because that's
the conversation I remember the most was
having was about Dave Winfield you were
you when you're plying between 28 and 32
32 being the highest of that window and
then you go on a decline by the time he
was 36 they were talking about
retirement 40 was a huge thing yeah and
then who's the guy that used to fight
chuckling down the guy in Vegas
nah he's IDO no no the white dude that
day doctor oh yeah for Jack horn quick
return yeah go to it change the game a
little bit you know uh Hopkins but
aren't Hopkins changed the game a little
bit you know boxing that's one yeah
showing you that there is life after
Foley and then working out you know and
you're gonna see it now in ten years
men are gonna be fighting at 44 and 45
the thing that's lemon in people now is
the head you know what you got the head
well listen after [ __ ] in 45 you
think you're doing things but you're not
doing it okay little bits a jump shot
whether it's in your mind you still have
that first when's it when's your
slinging dick prime Joey when does a man
is dick slinging prime
the crawl those years with the drums and
[ __ ] so have a chance arrived so funny I
mean I made the biggest best thing I did
five years ago was to walk into a
jujitsu studio it really showed me how
bad it was shaped I had become even
though I was lifting and doing all this
[ __ ] it really showed me what I had
become when my body was the first time I
did a hip escape I thought I've seen
stars and I left there and I said I'm
not gonna die I would go back and I know
what good is that gonna do for me if I
don't know back and I went back and it
was one it was down to once a week like
I was gonna teach it to our mondays and
I would be saw all week even though I
was going to the Y and swimming and
hitting the bag Jiu Jitsu had done
something to my body that hadn't been
done in their walk some setup it woke
some [ __ ] up and I became in love with
it but my movement and my weight was so
bad that I really wasn't moving forward
how it's not when I went to our boroughs
I started progressing cuz I started lose
a little weight but I was still 50 and
in your mind when you're 50 or 40 you
start looking at the younger guys I
think you're gonna why and I doing that
and sometimes you do there's a great guy
like Aubrey that'll go Joey come row
with me come on let's do another round
come on come on just let's just do
techniques I'll submit you you sweet me
and I would start doing that and then I
get the Carmichael you have a card you
have arranged the chiropractor you know
[ __ ] rub CBD all on me and farm you
know then I have a flight of something
and then I read this article about
training up over 50 and it really broke
it down and now do you know I'm training
five days a week since I saw some more
days a week it's [ __ ] awesome because
it's not what you're doing it's how are
you doing it yeah what length you're
doing it recoveries big you know I go to
cryotherapy I just started that a few
weeks ago the CBD oils the protein shake
so I went back to Weight Watchers you
know 55
five-year-old Ralphie made I'd eaten
[ __ ] jalapeno poppers you know hmm
my diet wasn't really bad at the time it
just needs to be cleaned up
you know butter on toast [ __ ] like that
that's it I'm then we're gonna eat
broccoli
I'm never gonna be equal no I'm never
gonna eat that you dis hummus Allah did
not even have a one in my house I don't
want it like I said one minute you know
how much texting you suck on ICE's big I
don't want to open up that window the
other saying that was how they got it
don't even bring people but mostly pita
breads just hungry for humma no I don't
leave it
I don't might be the but none of that
[ __ ] I don't like baba ghanoush I don't
like none of that [ __ ] no offense why
are we yeah was that's how they get us
in this country was a nice country and
that's how the [ __ ] ethics came in and
got you with their food it's delicious
Cubans everybody had its princess big
masters living on my block my mom
started cooking black beans and rice
fried banana loaf oh yeah white people
like man I hate them specs but I loved
that food [ __ ] Gerry Rocha out of
Texas a dear friend of mine he used to
have a joke about you know living in
Texas and you know how racist the white
people were in a man and you know like
listen look like he said he had a white
brother-in-law I haven't come over every
Christmas we just sit there and stare at
the Mexicans look at him [ __ ] up the
lyrics to jingle bell yeah but they sure
did good yeah yeah we joke like that
it's great to see you man yeah what
you're doing it's like I said I didn't
know about the Academy and I read about
and Joe filled me in on what was going
on and then when I was on our bernal's
to kick boxing coach was a great guy
when they came to me and he goes I'm
going on I'm moving to Austin is enough
and I see pictures of him on the website
Oh Alex I knew Shane yeah [ __ ] yeah
yeah he was yeah I didn't go didn't
remember that use it up Ernest he's
great yeah he was a lot birthdate such a
sweetie to and so good you know so good
so humble just a great coach yeah got a
lot of fighters on your roster
we gotta have we got a lot of fire
yeah yeah I mean Cody Garr Brandt Tyron
Woodley you know a lot of really Donald
Cerrone a lot of really top fighters who
we've been blessed to work with and
learn from and teach some things and
it's been it's been cool do you stop by
this gym ever in a Hollywood above the
Green Party of the blue pink taco pink
taco you live up there it's like what
was the guy that was with the UFC for
years no I haven't seen him he's always
on
he's on football what's his name yeah
Jay Glazer thought of his gym no but
I've seen it looks though look though
you should stop in there yeah pretty
neat place I think most of the guys cry
but I guarantee that most guys because
they're high level gems that celebrity
gems their gyms where people don't want
to be Bob you go out there you see the
chick that Luke used to date I think
works out there and what's the name the
singer the black the move out Jitsu girl
yeah that word teaches some jujitsu
there for a while but it's mostly like
football players like I saw the guys
yeah Johnny turf they got the whole
thing that looks a lot like I didn't
know it really is crazy
I mean the numbers come along they're
like for a guy like me I was like it
doesn't pay you know I don't just need
to move yeah that's that's what most
people need to do like exercise is a
[ __ ] miracle drug all we got to do is
take the minimum effective dose you know
like everybody's looking for some
prescription some magic thing exercise
will cure or at least treat like pain
depression anxiety sleep
sexual dysfunction it'll help you lose
body weight or to help you live longer
it's a [ __ ] miracle drug just move it
doesn't matter how you do it don't do it
for results don't compare yourself to
somebody else just take the drug that we
all have available that's free is [ __ ]
you know move your body that's it that's
all you got to do you know and that's
one of the things that I try and talk
about in my book that's coming out is
like you don't have to go to a fancy gym
you don't have to be a member on it but
you gotta move you gotta move
that's really human being needs to do
that's what we're designed to do and if
you start doing that then this miracle
that we're in will start working for you
instead of working against you and you
won't have this antagonistic
relationship with the
that you're in you'll start working
together you'll be on the same [ __ ]
team and then everything will start
sorting itself out like use the free
doctors [ __ ] sunlight sleep sex
exercise the cold use all that [ __ ] you
don't need to buy all the supplements
you don't need to go to the gym use the
stuff that you have available you'll be
[ __ ] 90% there it's it's crazy how my
calmly my life have changed since I
joined you Jitsu and now I'm not in a
jujitsu full time how I was I shop I
chopped it up with Muay Thai because the
conditioning is so much more high-level
and they have a 9:00 a.m. classes just
what we tried condition that you walk
out of there and everything's white your
underwear socks your [ __ ] everything
yes rash guard the t-shirt above the
rash guard I went to get coffee with my
wife one day after I dropped the baby
off and I just happened to see these
guys across the street it's my buddies
jujitsu school I wasn't going that I was
going rbirtle cray
but I'd watch these guys and I went to
home looked on the schedule and they had
Muay Thai class and I read up about the
guy and a friend of mine I bumped into
like a week later was going that he goes
brother nine o'clock all this is just
[ __ ] its circuits and then pass yeah you
know what that's like when you walk out
of that ten o'clock I walked out of
doing that today no it's the best it's
the [ __ ] it
now here's the problem I have a lot of
times like the reason why I was getting
the kettle bell from you know that stuff
is because this is one thing that I
don't know if you know about when you
live in California and you go for a
blood test do you know that I read this
statistic and I forgot what the number
is if somebody wants to throw it at me
but it is ridiculous how many people
will live in California a vitamin D like
like 80% of its if no it was even higher
yeah like 63% like huh and I remember
going in one time twice in a row for a
physical the doctor told Dawg you
vitamin D deficient and you gotta drink
more water
yeah you know now I have water next to
me in my sleep I wake up every time I go
to pee I drink a [ __ ] two swags
and it's so weird that I gotta tell you
something and I think this is the key
sometimes I really want to go to
kickboxing and I really want to go to
jujitsu but that Sun it's so [ __ ]
beautiful
the Sun is medicine man and people we
know we've been given such bad advice
that advice anyway from the Sun it's bad
no it's gonna [ __ ] heal you more
likely it's gonna you know convert into
vitamin D which you desperately need
absolutely definitely it's part of like
200-300 chemical reactions in the body
from your immune system to your mood to
your bone health like you need it and if
you don't get it that's one of the
things that you should supplement but go
for the Sun first guess what the sun's
free is [ __ ] take some time that's why
you feel so good at the beach you know
you're swimming you got your feet in the
sand you're getting some Sun you know
there's a reason you we feel good in
that was good they have scared you know
they scared people to the level where so
this days probably just go outside I met
my wife put like a little canopy up
mm-hmm and I go and I do it I swing the
kettlebells in the Sun above it and then
I go back under the canopy and I switch
exercises like I'll do stretch then go
back and I hit the bag on the Sun
sometimes it's too [ __ ] beautiful man
inside [ __ ] work and when I'm out
here in Venice you know sometimes I'll
go out to box and burn and I'll train
but most of the time I'm just running
outside or I'll go to the beach and play
around like bars are you ready I'm not
like a distance runner but I'll go for
like a jog and I'll sprint a few places
and I'll jump up on a [ __ ] park bench
for a little while and I just mix it up
you know because I don't like getting
stuck to the same routine that same
don't worry don't grow I just move you
know I don't need to achieve some great
athletic feat now but I want to be able
to play anything it's a [ __ ] beach
volleyball game breaks out I want to be
able to play that you know if someone's
playing a game of softball like and I
hit one in field home run chance I want
to be able to round the bases and make
it home you know and I want to be able
to play all the ways that I can play how
old you know 37 what do you feel like I
feel like I'm finally figuring a few
things out I feel like a body feel my
body feels pretty good having a
basketball injury
no not really not really like
everything's pretty good I got some feet
issues actually I think from the
basketball shoes is one of the problems
with shoes is that we made them too
narrow for too [ __ ] long and it
compresses all the bones and your feet
and then over time like now I have
problems with my big toe I got problems
with my feet and that's from the [ __ ]
shoes so now I get much wider shoes
because they make wide toe shoes now and
I get wider shoes which could give you
some blisters if you're really going
hard like if I was playing but over
overall it's way better for your body
and that's really the only thing that's
taken the biggest toll on me I have a
few back things and stuff most of that's
from you know the jiu-jitsu and from
some of the martial arts and from not
knowing how to lift kettlebells and
trying to show off before actually on a
gym came out and this is 10 years ago
and I'm like let me try to do this
snatch and I didn't know what the [ __ ] I
was doing so I have some other [ __ ] like
that but my body feels pretty good but
you know I have the best in the world
next door you know at my office like I
said 10 hours a day the best recovery
specialist the best training specialist
so you know I got every advantage in the
world it's crazy how I don't touch
nothing over 35 anymore I just don't say
max 135 minute and I was like that yeah
I was trying to throw up the gorillas
and now the war then no I was doing I
gotta be an Olympic lifter oh [ __ ] I'm
long yeah I couldn't I didn't know what
the [ __ ] was going on with my back for a
month I thought we switched mattresses
because I'm living the [ __ ] gorilla
like he's a 22 pound [ __ ] did you break
job with ever since I just been doing 35
yeah that's it I you know I used to try
to do 10 sets of 10 I'd do three three
and three I just included the Turkish
getup in that strength and conditioning
and I'd do it with 10 pounds on each
hand I'm real far away from [ __ ] Zurg
off their friends out there with a
primal swole jerk yeah primal [ __ ]
soldier but it doesn't matter because
I'm moving at 55 that's it now I want to
move at 65 but I'm gonna be lighter you
know I want to get away from 300 pounds
and much as I could yeah I mean there's
people out there
can't move enough to even have sex yeah
no no like I was there I thought was
there think I wanted pounds I just have
eat you [ __ ] in your house oh and I
pumped three times and shoot a nut I
couldn't even breathe the [ __ ] I've been
that I couldn't even breathe the
blessing out on life I would get so
excited that my fat little heart would
beat and I'd come in two minutes but I'd
sucked the hell out of your [ __ ] lick
your [ __ ] - the couldn't so [ __ ]
half a brain came out you know saying
let me give some shoutouts here real
quick get this party started
my man Tyler Ireland Jefferson Howry my
man Freddie Correa over there and his
beautiful wife in Vegas I haven't forgot
yet Justin Stephens get it together
[ __ ] Deva done Ally Brady Jordan
Branch comb Matt and dub and Alexander
Gonzales Santa Fe Albuquerque they had
an extra show at the Santa Ana casino
next week so Thursday night they had an
extra show the link is up I'm still
gonna Columbus for four [ __ ] 20 the
ice house is sold out on Saturday night
so I don't know what to tell you leaves
I'm gonna do a set Irene is gonna do a
set it's gonna be tremendous so let's
talk about to all be Markus [ __ ]
biography that's coming yeah lots of
biography more of a manual what I wanted
I mean I've been learning and I'm
constantly learning every day from the
best researchers the best doctors the
best athletes my own practices and I
wanted to take everything that I've
learned in this whole journey throughout
my life and put it into what the best
[ __ ] day you could live looks like
and that includes using all those free
doctors that I talked about like light
and the water and the movement and the
sex and the sleep but also you know what
the process is when you wake up from the
you know first thing you do drinking
water with a little Himalayan salt to
get your minerals up to getting setting
your circadian rhythm with the Sun to
using the cold to you know having that
glass of wine after your workout so you
have the least amount of alcohol to give
you the most buzz and your liver has to
process the last the least amount to
connect them with your family to what
you should eat from breakfast lunch and
dinner and and how did I create
something that wasn't all focused on
being super produc
they were super jacked or super skinny
but to just live a great [ __ ] life
and just focus on one day like how do
you live one [ __ ] day that you could
live over and over and over again
that'll build to the next day that won't
borrow from tomorrow to pay for today
but will make you able to have like the
best experience possible on this [ __ ]
amazing opportunity we have to be alive
make sense meds you know when I first
met you know I was [ __ ] up on drugs
and it was such a I look back at it and
I was like I was dead I was just walking
around dead basically I wasn't
exercising I was putting poison in my
body remember finding a shirt after I
moved I was clean two years I [ __ ]
found this shirt and you should see
there was a white shirt you should have
seen what the armpits look like this is
my coffee so what not toxins yeah it was
just pure toxins I was goofing around
with these guys the other day and I said
on the podcast that down and if you go
to Western in Hollywood Boulevard it's
all kinda heard there and on the corner
there was a really good restaurant next
door was like a Thai post office and had
this different Thai services and that
and one of the services they did was
they did like foot rubs and [ __ ] and
this lady had there yeah no no it was
legit the place there was no hand job
and what they did was uh they put your
feet these rocks that would suck out the
toxins in your body
bro this way they did not know me she
didn't uh no it's like I didn't tell her
anything and at the end when she tell me
to take my feet out she look at the
waters she go you do drops do you see
that that that that drops the one half
drunk and the other half died emini you
gonna have died a mini song and the
other half drunk they would form up yeah
she goes that's the drug and I couldn't
believe it that somebody knew my secret
you know sailing my system was so
[ __ ] high took like five might have
been cuz you're doing blow in front of
her though it wasn't doing blow no I
didn't do blowing today then I would go
in there at that time my addiction had
my mind that as long as I ate sushi
[ __ ] drink a little water
and maybe they got like a massage or
acupuncture the cocaine wouldn't matter
like my mind that told myself that I get
as long as I did one of those things the
next day exercise was not on the agenda
exercise was none to horizon I lived
across the street from the YMCA and I
used to treat it like it was a [ __ ]
prison like I wouldn't even look over
there like I wouldn't like it was like a
communist country Amin look at all these
don't even [ __ ] look over there it's
a bunch of women that got beat up more
[ __ ] living haha you know whatever
and then I started going over there and
I got addicted like I got addicted to
the way I was when I was a child with
basketball yeah and lifting and today
it's part of who I am but it's made me a
better comic everything is connected
that's ruining an art made me a better
cop
we could put the cherry on the sundae
that I was looking for because it
reminded me that comedy was an art and I
do call me how I do jujitsu I put your
my close guard and I make you try to
break and I try to slow you down on oh
man I ain't got time to play open God
and Baron ball Oh Jacqueline I'm gonna
put these two meat hooks around you and
let you figure it out by the time you
figure it out I try to slip in one
collar and by the time you get the other
one I try to slip the other one all I
got is a closed guard show yeah you know
I'm saying I've seen you [ __ ]
guillotine a thousand people no I had
the same time way on stage it's so funny
like well that guillotine people I feel
so bad that I gotta make it team because
I'm big I just hold them right there and
I go get out I'm dying to breathe
failure
you know I got like a minute and a half
and then I got whatever we're at I just
hold on to you boy that's why I don't do
noogie dawg yeah I can't do I'm a little
[ __ ] man I passed you god I gotta
stand your stomach for a couple minutes
you think about your life whether you
want to come back to the Jitsu I don't
hurt you I don't do knee on belly on
nobody I'm not a gorilla
yeah but I'm old and I gotta hit you
strong and young man by 19 years
if I pass you're gone I'm gonna lay on
your stomach you're not gonna breathe
you've only had a Joey Joey
I love lay a heavy I rolled with Kyle
kingsbere he's our director of human
optimization on one of my best friends
great guy great
guy and I had enrolled with a high level
black belt like that it was big I'm
Kyle's big and it was so humbling it was
amazing I sent a tweet out after that I
was like I am going to forfeit my white
belt and get a clear belt made of
[ __ ] stripper heels because I don't
even deserve a white belt you know after
I felt what he was able to do with me I
mean he could finish there was no safe
spots a man you know like half guard not
safe he pulled my head off or like take
my arm off and I'm like but I was in
half guard I thought I'm safe a nap no
you're not safe for now everybody's dead
yes I had a good dad his dad was yeah
wrestler very good to me so it's weird
like now I'm loved it I couldn't imagine
my world now without you Jitsu I accept
it for what it is I can't go more than
three times a week
I've hit five I hit five Jiu Jitsu but I
have to do it smart
two of the days I have to drill mmm I
can't roll more than three times I got
three five-minute rounds and that's it
after that I'd shake him if I do four or
five you're not gonna see me for four
days so many people do that
that's first day you go to the beach and
you don't wear any sunscreen you lay out
for eight hours and you get roasted you
can't go out in the Sun the rest of the
vacation people do the same [ __ ] working
out they go see a trainer and hit a
CrossFit gym and they just fry their
body and then they can't get back in for
a week better to go a little slower a
little snake time move you know I go I
go five days instead of to tell ya I was
comparing myself to what our burgers do
I can't my homeboy
why my wrestling Roger work to hit to
the debt why why might and why am i
swinging kettlebells after [ __ ]
jiu-jitsu class I should be stretching
yeah why am i swinging kettlebells and
then going to a [ __ ] car and you get
out of the car and you feel like your
back is locked up so the thing I added
now is I stretch I do to strength and
conditionings on my own but they're
basically it's a 30 minute stretch all
those are Berto stretches that he taught
me yeah all those tack fit stretches I
knew all that [ __ ] I get the joints
loosen up my wrist a [ __ ] tip-top
Magoo I do this flow this
Axford flow menu you know it's like a
hip escape boldwood one pop-up i could
pop up on one hand though yeah some of
it it's the weight but he was right
those bats broke all that debt what's
that what gets stuck around your bones
and you have to break it yeah what could
be scar tissue scar tissue and all that
[ __ ] so it's it's important what I'm
doing down this phase in my life and I'm
happy that you put out a book to give
somebody the perfect day because some
people don't really know yeah and
they're so me fifty five years it's and
there's so much bad advice out there and
it's just kind of clearing all that up
you know and really getting back to the
science there's like 300 clinical
references in there and and it's not
only that but it's the stuff that
actually works you know it's stuff that
sometimes the science will say one thing
like take a bunch of baking soda and
you're aerobic performance will get
better but you take the baking soda then
you just [ __ ] your pants and you're like
this doesn't make any sense you can't do
that so it's just that blend of all of
the people who have performed at the
high level what they're doing mixed with
what the best science says and then just
mix with experience like how do you
enjoy this thing and yeah it's called
own the day on your life it's at own the
day book.com if anybody's interested how
long it take you to write it [ __ ] two
years and my soul like I mean it's so so
challenging to write a book you know I
wrote it and then I rewrote and I
rewrote it and every time I'd look back
at my old work and be like oh my god I
was a child when I wrote this
you know just the art of actually
producing the writing and really putting
everything I had in it you know that was
you know I gave it all I had I know that
there's not one ounce of more effort
that I could have put in this book so
it's the very best I can do so well you
know I hope people love it but I'm going
in there without any nerves or worry
about what's gonna happen on opening day
you know when it releases or whatever
because I know I put my soul in it and
that's it's the best I'll get released
April 17th okay you have like a little
party and on it yeah I'm gonna have a
party and on and I'll have a party out
here in LA and a wanderlust or and then
I'll be at the Strand in New York and
signing books and hanging with people
and sharing the love good for you man
yeah I'm excited man you know when you
first came in I told you that I called
you last week and you didn't answer
after one of the bump like the second
bombing
I got a little concerned with you I
called my other friend don't run whites
down there and it's like you know you
see a place like Austin that it's not
Houston yeah it's not Dallas which I'm
not knocking by any means I'm just a
same like city sighs you don't like
embarrassing you have the Dallas Fort
Worth area in my mind I think it's
bigger than Austin and for something
like that to be happening in such a
small yeah
white great little community one of the
one of the bombings was on the street
that I take to go to work so we saw the
all the media all the fire trucks and
everything else out there the the really
tricky thing about that is when someone
does that it incites so much more fear
than the actual damage you know like one
car crash probably has killed more
people you know than all the people from
that bombings but when you take
something like packages which we rely on
because we're always ordering [ __ ] from
Amazon and they make you scared of that
then it just spreads fear and fear is
that deepest virus that we have so it's
challenging you know there was something
about Amazon wanting to have your keys
so we could go into your house or
something they sell a camera let you you
can put in you how well they actually
bought ring so I think they're gonna
change it to that but they have a camera
that you'll put in your front door so
that you can give them the key and then
the guy can put the box inside your
house it's okay yeah it's getting a
little too crazy self-driving car for
I'm not gonna get in a car there's
another driver
okay I don't wanna be in a car I want to
see no Total Recall John cab if you know
if you buy one of those cars on my block
I will give you a flat tire here I used
to flatten people's tires take care of
their tires because the bus is two
blocks away over here so I would have
lose my parking spot to people they made
me walk around if you left your car in
front of my house but I learned that
from my father
I saw that when I was growing up Grove
you parked in the front of that house
he's a Cuban man
and then his world that's his house I
know that's a public sidewalk but don't
meddle Park in front of my house
and people park in front of the house
he'd get home at 3:00 from the bar
and he'd go out there or he need to take
the air out of your tire or slash your
tires so you got the message don't party
huh
and I have to do the same thing when I
break on this block because people
parking fire I give them like an Howard
to and I'd scratch their [ __ ] car
just out of [ __ ] principle you think
I'm [ __ ] with your dog there was one
guy we just draw off my garbage in this
truck it's driving him crazy and it was
driving me crazy I was watch him from my
window look at his truck and shake his
hair and go [ __ ] didn't even take the
garbage out put it in the garbage cans
[ __ ] there's people that would [ __ ]
park there and take a cab to Burbank
Airport and leave the car if your car is
in my name after three days it's going
down it's gone you know what else I used
to do there's these guys that I [ __ ]
hate there's a certain animal that I
[ __ ] hate and that's the guy that
buys no BMW 7-series
but instead of paying for parking over
at the train station he parks on my
block that's the first car I scratched
with the key I've scratched being
anything nice that I know you're a piece
of [ __ ] like you're a gutless really so
you bought a Mercedes to show your
friends how cool you are but you walk
three blocks like a [ __ ] Puerto Rican
on the fourth to save the tool hours and
parking really huh
I'm scratching your car I call it
justice I caught a guy brand new one he
had just got in the car
oh I got that [ __ ] good don't
Park in my neighborhood no more I
probably disappeared or they bugged out
hey I think I'm kidding you I send the
stern warning in my [ __ ] neighborhood
it could let me note or something no
notes no nothing don't party here you
know but gana this is my [ __ ] night
but you'll need to park when I saw God
you think I'm kidding there was a guy
out there that have brand-new like one
of those bubble [ __ ] poor [ __ ] bro I
just drew a rock at the [ __ ] door
when he came I was out there just doing
kettlebells making believe cuz I would
waste helping the local body shops
joking out in the economy Armenians I
don't [ __ ] around
don't Park on my block you know how long
do I know you know you know even a man
six years
oh no it's gotta be more than cuz you
peruse you're talking about Caitlin it's
like nine years yes I saw you when you
were a kid and put the whole honor thing
together hey man you [ __ ] did a a
great thing I'm happy that you sent me
stubborn muster because I really love
the shroom tank and I told you my
experience with the Alpha brain which we
won't tell the public you ever figured
out for your [ __ ] selfish [ __ ] super
awful yeah the same when I [ __ ]
figure that figure and I didn't figure
out anything I just made a mistake one
day I didn't worked out my favor that's
discovery I was like what the [ __ ]
happened to me last night
Oh [ __ ] alpha brain anyway what is it
book come on April 17th but anybody
who's interested in pre-order the free
water yeah because that tells the
bookstores that the book is interesting
so it's super helpful for the author so
just go on the day book calm or Amazon
or wherever I just checked it's number
one on Amazon oh [ __ ] oh and the an
exerciser fitness it is crazy that I
remember talking to you having a
conversation you maybe 7 years ago I
knew nothing about you I thought you
were some [ __ ] kid who hit the
lottery and you would just [ __ ]
faking the funk and I have time for say
surely you and I fell in love with you
about the basketball home which we
understand basketball and we're on the
same page but you schooled me one night
on protein yeah you don't remember I
think you had a couple cocktails and you
would talk to this and it was one of
those nights when I really listened to
you and I you were explaining to me
about the chocolate and your what was
the name well it was hemp force now you
got me all [ __ ] announced now we call
power food how this is still the same
chilean formula exactly so far and I'll
never forget like there's certain
conversations I've had with certain
people that made me fall in love with
them like I always thought that he Bravo
was a [ __ ] lunatic until he told me a
story about his love for kiss one day I
got high he told me his story about his
love
could four kiss howling everybody turned
on kids he still loved kiss and he would
have to go buy the album and put it
under his shirt and walk home and then
hide it until his brother came home and
you know and these are the conversations
having me fall in love with people I
don't fall in love with people with
regular [ __ ] I like when I get that
and I found love with you because you
were explained to me the research and
what you had done to get the flavor
mm-hmm and I'm sitting oh there's a
[ __ ] my flame and then I tasted it now
I'm hooked on and I was babbling pissed
I'm waiting to you come on ha ha ha ha
to tell you that I want my [ __ ] hemp
we got you man Oh got you myself
have you got enough protein bites yet
your head's gonna [ __ ] explode one of
the protein it's 60 different plants
that we wrapped in like a ribs really
low sugar only 5 grams of sugar we
wrapped it in dark chocolates coconut
cashew protein bites oh it's like it's
like almond joy and your best protein
bar had sex it's [ __ ] incredible
like we're really and I'd you know I was
like really hands-on with with the hemp
force act right oh that's what like I
made it in my kitchen and I was running
around ever getting a conversation that
made me fall lovely and this one now you
know now we're big enough where the best
formulators the best food specialists
will come up with these amazing
combinations of adzuki beans and all
this crazy stuff that they'll compress
so you get all the micronutrient profile
and then we'll come up and we'll
brainstorm flavors I like I want
something that tastes like an almond joy
but has the best macro micro nutrient
profile you can get and they'll lay
there if they're able to deliver it and
so it's like it's really cool what we're
able to what we're able to put together
now you know I remember watching
something and it was about vitamin
companies how they had no regulations
and people who can give a [ __ ] and have
to shoot you eating those protein pills
like you know I'm naive that stuff I got
it last time I was on Joe's a Hass show
about GNC do they really have it can I
go into GNC and buy [ __ ] the host a
couple he's like oh my god they got like
three things though you go in there
anabolic like ill test pilot for and
[ __ ] like that
so that was why the conversation with
you that day was so intriguing because I
really believed that you really really
really wanted the best chalk like yeah
you you have a few bhaktas in you but
you were so passionate about it that I
fell in love with the conversation sure
I could tell when somebody's faking the
funk you were like you don't understand
this cocoa or whatever the [ __ ] a cow or
whatever you call it it's the best you
went somewhere yeah Peru or something
and you've got something in you and I
left there knowing that wasn't the most
fast got to see somebody's true colors
yeah place I didn't know what the [ __ ]
were most people just say you know what
I want to bet the chocolate I wanted to
taste like a yoohoo not you yeah you
were looking for the best tasting
chocolate like I remember we we we
discussed wala Hara then what's that
going whether that chocolate company
guava like how we were up in [ __ ] San
Francisco nobody knows where it
Ghirardelli Ghirardelli we Ghirardelli
like about chocolate and the flavors now
and I'm believing they're like having
the conversation with you and then
leaving there and thinking I'm one of
those guys I think about it later than
going when he comes up with this I'm
gonna try it because it was like me he's
not a fat guy he's a thin healthy guy
telling me how flavor is important
that's important to fat people cuz I'm
like when I'm gonna go Jesus Christ ate
over sushi Dan that's this [ __ ] this
cloth sizzling albacore it's just an
albacore with onions and peppers and
jalapenos when you take the wasabi and
you mix it with the soy and you collect
over salami I'm on there and you put the
huh and let me get you see the flavor
I'm selling us that's how were you were
selling things hahaha that's what you
was so yeah and I've been drinking those
chocolate shakes and I was 10 years I
went I went on a chocolate shake I I'd
do my own experiments and I got to the
point where I would do two scoops which
is 32 grams of protein 16 scoop
16 grams per scoop I would do two and I
wouldn't have to eat till after our burn
oh crap
that was one o'clock on two scoops yeah
that's how I fell in love with it I fell
in love with the flavor you know
sometimes I mixed it with water
sometimes I missed it with milk
depending what I was doing that day
chocolates so cool too it's like four
psychoactive components like peña and
and amides theobromine it's got all
these things interact with the body and
like a really cool healthy way it's got
magnesium which is great for your
muscles plus all you know the additional
protein and fiber and the amazing flavor
I mean there's so many great things out
there you know when you're not having
the nestle [ __ ] version you're
actually going to the source you know
where the cacao bean is and actually
when when you're in Peru and you
actually have the fruit that the cacao
nibs and the cacao beans are from the
fruit tastes like papaya but better in
some ways with like a mango it's like
crazy to understand the plant and the
tree they're like the fruit like grows
off the trunk of the tree you know and
like that's chocolate it's not a little
it's not a little silver kiss with a
little thing coming off the top you know
you like see trace it back to what this
thing is and then really appreciate it
and you know I love I love that stuff
and that that gets me fired up and so
I've tried to translate that as much as
I could and I like the vanilla yeah but
my favorite is the the chocolate with
the chocolate that's why it'll nothing
community listen man I want you thank
you for taking the time I've been trying
to love Jeannette for a couple years I
appreciate you so much I appreciate you
too and you know I love your products
and I'm a user and I wish I did more
videos for you nobody's ever around when
I'm doing club bowels and [ __ ] not my
wife so one of these days I'll tip done
you know the hottest shirt you sent me
fits now hell yeah like the 2x didn't
fit at first and I put it in the corner
I go I'll be back [ __ ] to take the do a
video and I forgot I was sweaty so when
I'm going wife goes yeah
why'd you put the shirt on
cuz I go I want them to know I was doing
the club bus she's like look at it it
looks terrible Mouse and so I bailing
the whole [ __ ] thing but now the two
egg finally fit me so I'm happy bro
thank you very much for coming on of
course brother let's do the out of that
together listen as far as supplements
are concerned you want to do your body
right you heard what the man said you
want you you want to get the most out of
your day for me man the new mood has
helped you know I fly a lot so I'm a big
shrimp tech immune guy you know you
wanna plane you see a Chinese guy with a
mask on I got [ __ ] I got sure you kiss
him on the mouth nose you got shroom
checking me no no no listen between the
shrooms that community swimming in the
Hudson as a kid I'm bulletproof
I eat ass all those component like row
by a little be eating ass a couple
shrimp Tech immunes and swimming in the
Hudson
I'm pissed on me I like it I don't even
get the fool no more that's [ __ ]
strong so between the shroom tech immune
the shrimp export the the what is it the
shake now it's called power food power
food it's changed my life give it a try
take a chance Columbus did what do you
know you you gonna stick with your same
[ __ ] protein and your same stuff you
got it you gotta do variety and your
workout and that's what we're talking
about you got to switch it up go to
icarly.com
look a great selection of supplements
that they have from the jerky that's
good I got my little bit but they're not
kind of good to the tenant now you get
these send me these [ __ ] chicken nibs
I'm gonna have to hire the property
rights or protein buys you know crazy I
love that [ __ ] yeah especially at night
when you're a stoner oh man I don't mind
eating something as long as I know I got
some protein in it I'm gonna send it to
you immediately and I'm gonna call you
as soon as you get it
bah boom that's what I'm talking about
go to alikom right now press a church
and get 10% off delivered right to your
[ __ ] door the beginning of the
podcast I ask you are you lonely
are you lonely are you sick and tired of
being alone in that apartment by
yourself petting a cat your dog whatever
this is what I wanna talk to you about
all right
because Philly has been single for a
while what's your experience with
Ireland
harmony Lee I just I was really
impressed with them with how seriously
how in-depth the questions are so you
really get to know if the person that
they're matching you with you have a lot
of common you have similar it's not just
oh D like cats and dogs they go deeper
than that so it's it's very nice
listen e harmony takes the steps of
other dating sites don't in order to
find you more compatible match it's
built to help you find long lasting
meaningful relationships not a shallow
hook-up site all right you can have
those on your own they have helped over
1 million people find their perfect
match they use decades of science data
psychological research to send you the
right matches eat harmony brings
compatible people together there plenty
of hookup sites out there I don't blame
you but this is not what this is the
number one trusted dating site or app
based on a 2018 survey of 1600 US
singles based on a 200 1800 survey of 69
US singles right now my listeners the
family can get a free month eHarmony
when you sign up for a three month
subscription and the code church at
checkout it's that easy stop waiting and
start your journey to a satisfying
meaningful relationship don't you want
to be in love I am in love Jill I know
don't you want to go to the beach and
run around and hold hands and eat ice
cream listen go to he harmony right now
right now you you can have fun it's fun
to play around with online dating out
for when you're ready to fall in love
with somebody and start a family and
have a meaningful relationship there's
only one app built to bring your real
love and that's he harmony come see how
he harmony can change your life right
now go to he Omnicom and get started
at the code church at checkout stop
sitting at home watching TV by yourself
it's time you want to change your life
have sex with life that's right and
don't forget pick up my main man's book
coming out April 17 you order right now
number one on [ __ ] Amazon I wish you
nothing but love
thank you brother that success and
hopefully next time my man Austin you
all be on one of your [ __ ] Malaysian
[ __ ] no
and watching boom movie video I love you
bad don't forget the Saturday sold out
at the ice house I think this is a thing
but we had an extra show now week from
tomorrow at the Santa Ana casino it's a
ten o'clock show hopefully I'll see you
and I'm not
I'll see you dirty savages in Columbus
420 stay black have a great weekend and
we'll see you again Monday more than
happy East at all you [ __ ] I love
you Thank You Lee Thank You Aubrey I
love you guys peace